hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Resident Evil 7 now
we got a croc situation in that Creek
and we got to take care of it so don't
worry Zoe I'm gonna go get a cure
somehow and try not to think about how I
ruined everything with that croc go hey
how are you going you're not scared of
hitting 50 I know how it'd be hello Oh a
stealth kill you say what are you doing
here
stealthy oh the silent issed
they have a croc head that don't make
any sense at all how this can't be here
long enough to get a croc ooh hey you
want some a hideous e aimed I guess I
could have snuck up on you it didn't
seem to matter
oh it's a fast one oh holy [ __ ] those
guys those guys don't take I gotta get
kicky kicky and swifty involved god
alright well time to come in low I guess
all right let's see what I resent sure
I'm happy with how that went down
God you know I don't know if I'm not
picking up a gun by choice or if it's
just the only way he knows how to fight
yeah all right let's try to be a little
more stealthy about all this hello hello
oh there you are
okay and there you go you ain't gonna
know this big giant man is the
stealthiest around it's all that
football I played definitely got my
stealth and skills up was this grub
through a microscope what cat side is
look this grub would mix well with cam
fluid for some reason alright oh hey
buddy
[Laughter]
you know I don't know if those things
feel pain but actually now I'm pretty
sure they do all right well now it's fun
glad I did that but also why ooh
stabby stick Wow just like I used to
throw the football back in my foot in
days
all right then wham bam I love this so
much and I'm gonna be permanently stuck
in an accent from now on oh boy I got
two tiny punching Peters whatever I
called them alright Jesus is so funny I
love this so much oh man you guys don't
understand the bold choice of turning
Resident Evil into a punching game like
I can't believe it but also I'm so happy
they did all right
orders are as follows effective
immediately the Muta my site is on loose
in the swamp and it'll keep mutating as
it encounters new organisms we can't
allow the stock and medicine compounds
to be exposed if they suffer a mutation
they'll be useless transfer the whole
anti-infective synthesizing station over
to the paddleboat
oh yes the paddleboat the most defensive
of all military compounds yeah no joke
about that one there Pappy slim so uh
any ancient coins around here alright
anyway I'm gonna keep going ah my lamp
oh no cuz oh oh oh oh well hi you want
to go you best stay back now yes you
won't be a hit Ian swifty pity and Lefty
alright come on come on hop
Oh miss me ah follow-up
who'd have thought I forgot yet if Wow
no oh you tired are you tired flight
okay miss me
you suck whap whap whap whap whap and no
Wow nice hey maker whoa Katja I call
that a counter Oh I'll kick really I'm a
punch right in your ass that's what you
deserve
oh yeah oh that's what I call a combo oh
oh no you ain't my fist made sure that
you made a grub ooh you look like y'all
grub grub grub oh there's grub okay fine
then I'll be on my way I suppose
all right enough grubbing up a storm
here
rub-a-dub-dub rub it on a rock this far
from the creek
all right fine then I'll call him a
crawdad there difference between crawdad
and crawfish as a kid oh hey Wow hey
ya ain't gonna happen or get back up I
don't care
fine by me oh whoa whoa kick your ass I
know your weak spot
Fifty's going to town on that ass oh now
whoa I fell oh let me put some grub
juice on me yeah well you want some oh
I'll come back
oh come I'll come back up want your
ankles buddy oh really oh yeah you
better run I fell down this small alcove
and thusly you can't fight me no mo all
right find that alright sure ok grub yum
yum yum ooh convenience oh do you I
gotta go in this building over here oh
this is the best the best thing ever
crawdad all right sure sure why not all
right hello
ah there's still all of tawny punching
Peterson man they sure are giving me a
ton of these save points here so exactly
like is the most most intrepid
adventurer going between these that I've
ever seen but you know I'll take what I
can get it's so fun lock from the other
side ok so I guess I guess I can't just
punch that Gator now can i you want to
get speared oh you want to get speared
whoa Wow Wow well where are you going
wait wait it's not that deep well it's
not that deep oh I mean it feel terrible
for that my Gator Oh point you Gator Wow
well alright then fair fair fair I
suppose I suppose that's fair fair
alright okay alright hi Zoey how you do
alright we'll take two so
rule number on don't punch the Gators
rule number three oh that one oh that
was always there flap another one
another spear perfect I'm glad these are
just here lying in the water perfect for
me okay oh ha ha
if I'd have missed that I would've been
eternally boned huh
All Right see ya oh well Oh wowie Zowie
I'm out of Spears okay I'm just gonna
hold that's that's no good that's no
good oh oh oh okay all right that seems
better yeah I'll go up this way instead
of going to certain death which is
usually what I like to do in these games
eh oh come on did the light give me away
all right fine then clamp whap whap whap
whap whap whap whap whap wham whoa I
don't remember what the actual combos
are so Oh what tap what's that
Oh couldn't hear you can you speak up oh
oh yeah god I feel so strong this is not
usually normal life I do not usually
really strong hey you get up here Gator
on the pier I'm assuming that all this
territory is mine and not anybody else's
all right well you you have a nice nap
now Gator no no sir I can't be seduced
like that
jeez I wonder what the know what the
infection is gonna do to those when they
fully infect him probably not too fun if
I had to guess all right Gator good
thing I got this amazingly advanced
spear shoot photo right in your butt
hole
so so read your ear I guess alright see
you see you well well this must be the
back door to that other shed you think
I'd be with my punching skills I could
just bash my way through that but new
alright well there we are
alright let's see another no not there
not there hope okay
sorry I just I'm tickled to death by
this game it's not usually you know this
Resident Evil 7 it was a big surprise
when it came down to it being a like a
fun game number one but number two the
bigger surprise was that it had this
interesting like tongue-in-cheek nature
to it that was oops sorry it had this
like tongue-in-cheek nature to it that
just made it a a really like genuine
experience like it was a game especially
in the DLC and stuff it was a game that
took itself as a game more than it took
itself as like a super serious story
which is why it leads to like
incredulous moments where it's like okay
alright that's a little that's a little
silly Billy there but you know it's it's
just really fun and and I think that's
that's emphasized it's both fun and
scary like it can do all of it and and
it's kind of a trend that's happening in
in like modern media today there's a lot
more like horror movies and horror genre
stuff that has like a little bit of
humor to it and I think like the kam
penis of old style like of like the old
horror movies like it was always campy
and it was always a little
tongue-in-cheek because it was so
ridiculous and we got away from that a
little bit I'm like I'm not a hundred
percent sure there's plenty of movies it
took them so seriously but that little
bit of like sardonic humor you know the
little touch of sarcasm throughout the
entirety of it that's that's what I
really liked about some of these horror
things and I think this game actually
puts that forward in a really good way
and I don't know I just love it because
whoa oh whoa hey what how am I gonna
punch your head with spikes in it it's
[ __ ] alright well you're new
okay oh hey sent you spiraling can I
stop you are you just dead okay he's
dead alright well that was weird
yeah but it's it's just the little
evolutions that lead it down a road
where it's semi-serious centipede semi
serious and yet so lovable like Jill
Baker sure yeah Joe Baker doesn't exist
he was contrived after the thought and
this is just uh this is just like a oh
this is just an environmental thing that
allows people to have a little bit more
fun with what they're doing and that's
good because sometimes that's needed
which way you going okay all right
oh hello oh you're twitchy huh oh you're
gonna be twitch here now okay anyway got
it go on wait why did they put this on
the paddleboat like putting it on the
path I'm assuming I'm on the phatal bow
right now I've got three breaths six
strong tree branch can't be used as is
of course of course you can't stay glued
on this tree oh boy
man if I'm putting that on grubs and
they turn into medicine and I put it on
a branch and it turns into a bomb oh
it's so fun press left click to stick it
on the ground plus are to detonate that
makes no sense
how did I make this with there's no
sense
oh you want to go toe-to-toe buddy all
right all right let's go
all right let's go let's go oh wow wow
he's not tough you think I'd hurt my
hands on him but new hello scrap-metal I
don't take that all right what else we
got
oh is that just the other way that I
could have crawled through let me see if
there's a well that's probably the cure
station let me see if there's a grub in
this thing or maybe a tree branch oh
well I don't like that guy he seems to
wait wait wait put it on the grill okay
all right you coming over here come on
oh okay all right wait I got this
was it the tree branch or the chemical
that causes it to beep all right he's
getting closer guys he's getting closer
you couldn't close I somehow got a
remote for this tiny punching Peter oh
boy
I'll saved you from that box charred
followed on you oh look it's a free
throwing spear this is the greatest
thing I've ever seen in my life you know
ordinarily you know in some games they
could do these sort of things and I'd
just be like I is ridiculous but this is
ridiculous in such a good way in such a
honestly and truly good way it's so good
oh man hang on I got to read up on my
punching skills again because I want to
just make sure that I got it right left
left left okay left right right right
right left left left okay those are the
two combos got it and I'm sure there's
more combos that I could do but I just
don't know him right now
all right who's there high-low guy or
fisticuffs man what are we gonna do
about this
Oh ah okay well well I cool I can sneak
up on you all right hey you're not gonna
see me what are you even doing
he's just sick on the ground is like I
can't find my contacts and I just rip
his freaking head off cuz I'm an [ __ ]
like that all right what do we got
yeah everything seems marginally less
scary when I know that I can just punch
things to death I'm gonna eat some
critters so not bad
slimy yet satisfying okay all right
where we going now
oh boy I love this I love the sauce our
grub in this box long tree the tree
branch was bigger than the box oh
there's the funniest [ __ ] I've ever seen
in my life okay I could go down here let
me explore around first oh wait no some
tells me there's gonna be the secret
sneaky way which is the way that I like
to go and the way that I'm definitely
gonna be going so there we go
what do we got whoa whoa whoa champion
effigy oh [ __ ] a creepy doll use for
black man is that what they are for
black magic champion effigy all right I
got I got way more punching power all
right oh I hope there are minigames
associated with this game mode there
better be like an unlimited mode after I
get done whoa hello hi well yeah
okay and ya miss me oh you are you dead
you dead you're twitching like he ain't
dead oh god the way your teeth move that
ain't natural
alright need another grub haha what a
freakin badass wha what a amazing human
being
what an incredible person and how does
that heal him I wonder I wonder I wonder
with thunder how how does that work I
don't know and I don't care oh that's a
spear okay well how did it get there who
threw it it was jutting that way oh no I
don't understand I don't know anything
but I am amazed I am just amazed can I
climb up here can I not climb up here oh
yeah okay alright okay alright gotta go
the stairs yeah I can't climb up the two
feet that it would require to be able to
do that yeah definitely not okay alright
well then let's go in here then and have
a great time alright now we're gonna get
the cure and hopefully something's gonna
arise out of this auto synthesizer yeah
this is definitely the safest place for
this surrounded by all these no not
everything solved by punching Joe Joe
[Laughter]
let's really uh no game is made me laugh
more than this game apparently of all
hey you were oh geez
[Laughter]
Wow okay he just threw me oh gee I guess
it's time to go toe-to-toe with Joe all
right come on man you want some of this
oh yeah oh yeah yeah holy crap
whoa okay
all right you want to go I got all my
skill in there yeah that's right oh yeah
oh yeah yeah you ain't gonna do this
whoa
come on whoa come on
yeah yeah hey I got a restore smell got
slapped some goop juice on me don't mind
me I'm gonna see what that what's in
this whoo hey that's nice
all right okay all right yeah give it to
me
what am i given to you what the hell hey
how's garden ho
oh you didn't say that we could use our
heads
I've never used my head for anything
Nathan day in my life whoa oh yeah
Justine whoa whoa God I got a branch
I got a branch Hanna Marin ah [ __ ] yeah
you got a branch
oh [ __ ] I'm out cam fluid I got whoa
whoa what was that
are you trying to do there come on ma
come on Oh miss me Frick all right
[Music]
huh-huh-huh-huh-huh
here we go here we go here we go here we
go Oh backhand come on now oh hey I'm
blocking how I blocked come on there we
go get some hey I gotta get some grub
juice on me I'm gonna think about this
one yeah got on the ropes now oh whoa
miss me miss me baby
Oh
Wow
okay okay okay yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah the finisher the finisher baby I
call this one the I don't know what I'm
doing
what grabbing your breath oh man who
know that these uh who knew these
horrible evolutions of fungus and virus
weren't the peak pinnacle of evolution
cuz Wow Joe man Joe Joe Joe Joe
Wow I am impressed time to celebrate
with a grub come on Joe you know you
wanna go Joe baby Joe Joe no no oh call
you no no Joe Joe oh boy Wow all right
well anyway got what I came for I guess
ah good chem fluid I can make that bomb
I wanted to be perfect
got a bomb which is exactly what I
needed all right shoot illudude alludu
making my way back to Zoey now I guess
Oh is anything gonna actually stand in
my way oh I swear I'm a giggly [ __ ] but
you know this is this is goddamn funny
this is so funny
Oh what's gonna stop me oh oh come on
hey
what well that's not good oh you want to
go for round three huh round three huh
I'll get you free round three okay
anyway that's all the time we got for
this episode but god damn this is the
funniest thing I've ever seen so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought down the
comments below and as always I will see
you next video
[Music]